les sujets de conversation préféré de
69% des Français sont les POS AES
collègues et ça c'est vra et j'en
profite je pense que chacun va raconter
un potin sur une personne autour de la
table donc je vous laisse je vous laisse
le temps du pour raconter un petit potin
et si vous ne le faites pas attention je
le ferai moi-même donc t ça va être
chaud c'est
parti que ce soit à la cantine en pose
devant le bureau ou encore à la machine
à café les salariés adorent discuter
entre eux
tu as l'air en forme toi ce matin je me
trompe et une étude réalisée auprès de
plus de 900 personnes que vient de
publier l'Institut hiop permet d'en
savoir plus sur les discussions des
employés si la religion les relations
amoureuses ou encore le salaire figure
parmi les sujets à bout combien est-ce
que vous gagnez par mois je sais pas si
j'ai envie de le dire en fait 66 % des
salariés sondés affirment aimés se
plaindre de leur patron et de
l'entreprise mais 69 % d'entre eux soit
la majorité déclare que leur sujet de
conversation préféré sont les petits
potins entre
[Musique]
collègue qui a un potin moi ah ou quand
même ah la vache j'ai pas eu
besoin d'aller le chercher très loin il
remonta hier soir Raymond sort en
émission tu vois ce que je veux dire bah
très gentiment qu'on vien une partous en
île
[Musique]
de c'est un M c'est un M un M
[Applaudissements]
sortez tous s' sortez tous s'il vous
plaît sortez tous complètement sortez
s'il vous pla c'est pas de votre âge
sortez mais tu GES tout le
monde à
fa demandez mais demand demandezli si
c'est vrai ou onand Pasir pas ce genre
de truc mais tu sais qu'on a la télé là
on est en direct les gens nous regardent
mais tu es un malade on est le premier t
de France ah merde ouais tu es con comme
une Sabate c'était c'était un monopolie
non mais c'est ils vont rentrer tu vas
la refaire ah d'accord ok allez
rerentrer e rerentrer rentrer e
oh demandezlui chef
demandzli allez mets-toi là toi mets-toi
là mais je su pas d'accord je pas
d'accord je pas d'accord attention on
rigole mais faut pas inventer non plus
on veut bien faire des parce que tu sais
que les gens nous regardent là alors ton
pote hein ton pote un vrai hein un vrai
vrai moi je repars un vrai travaille
demain je repars
pasrai vrai un vrai hier
[Rires]
soir mais j'allais préciser la ville au
moins sa
mort ah
oui ple mais tu es conain mais
qui sa femme regarde sa femme regarde
l'émission je savais pas dé sais pas ah
oui ah
oui mais c'est vrai qui qui me
contredent les yeux dans les yeux les
yeux dans les yeux dis-moi ce que tu
veux dire les yeux dans les yeux non dis
dis dis une vérité bon les mecs les mecs
que je attz c'est fait le tour potin et
on reviendra là-dessus on fait le tour
on fait tour un autre potin
vous alors Jacques cardose nous a dit
qu'il travaillait et qu'il avait pas eu
le temps de regarder le film et je sais
de sources sûr que c'est faux puisque
cet après-midi je suis allé Anab de V
qui est voyante qu'on avait vu sur le
plateau et il se trouve qu'il était là
juste avant
[Rires]
moiier vousz dans
instant ban une B
ony fa les mecs donnez pas tout tout de
suite on est non mais c'est vrai ça va
on est on est le 16 novembre on on a
jusqu'en
juin je ne dévoilerai pas mes sources le
13 avril 2017 lorsqu'il était à France 2
Jacques cardose à Ken Daniel Morau
comment ça tu mais lour arrê un estce
que vous êtes lourd non nul nul nul n on
voit bien que c'est
impossible alors oui tu es lourd alors
oui vrai potin qui en a qui a levé la
main tout à l'heure moi j'ai levé la
main j'ai non pas un potin mais un petit
tac à Jacques cardose au nom de tous mes
collègues alors maintenant juste avant
qu'on continue tu sors de la piscine
là niveau peekou frère dis-moi tu étais
en papillon et encore encore 10 minutes
ou quoi on dirait la peekou que tu as
quand tu sors de la piscine à l'école
mais donc bah j'ai des petites
tentatives capillaires non c'est vrai
que cardos devient insupportable il
travaille de moins en moins et
maintenant il exige des moto taxis pour
se déplacer sinon il ne vient plus et
ben écoute il viendra plus des moto taxi
cro pas un instant jacqu un menteur
menteur j'ai bon je veux bien ah vous
êtes prêts non
mais non mais je dois dire les choses fa
établir la vérité Mo rien donc hier soir
je suis monté après l'émission
effectivement j'ai vu une conversation
très animée entre Jean-Michel mer et
Raymond
allez
[Applaudissements]
memmer normalement je suis dis je on va
revenir à toi est-ce que tu as un potin
oui alors ça s'est passé hier
soir loge
démaquillage c'était avant ou après
l'émission jeprèsémissionr après
l'émission d' les gens vont croire là ah
il après l'émission alors vas-y C après
l'émission oui juste après l'émission et
Raymond très gentiment m'a entrepris m'a
dit qu'est-ce que tu fais ce soir je lui
ai dit bah j'ai déjà quelque chose et
cetera il me dit c'est dommage parce que
je suis convié à Saint mort des fussé
n'importe quoi il est fou le mec il
donne même des
ves le mot le mot sort de sa bouche une
partous il y
aura conneries les G tu balances des
villes arrête tes conneries villes oui
oui c'est
pas lui il sarrête à la ville il
vaueer
la
mais il m'a dit on sera 16 don lui
[Applaudissements]
estce tu rentr dormir
hiergoû vous me dégoûtez vous me
dégoûtez pour pourquoi on ser qu'il faut
amener un gâteau dans ces can je
comprends pas en fait tu arrives d'abord
tu pass chez passis une galette des rois
pour il y a une cagnotte c'est pour
offrir hein merci non mais c'est un truc
de fou et là franchement euh bravo
Jean-M mais de
quoi non pas bravo bravoi tu portes
plainte pour diffamation alors sur
Jean-M ou c'est un ami je veux pas
porter mais s'il faut je porter je
précise que tout à l'heure dès que je
l'ai croisé je lui demandé si était allé
il m'a dit oui et je suis explosé il m'a
dit il m'a dit il m'a dit je suis crevé
regarde il m'a dit ça ou
pas les applaudisse normal comme si
racontait que j'avais été chercher du
pain mais jure que c'est jure que c'est
faux J de mes enfants c'est vrai ça y
est
les enfants faut les en de de ça quand
même non là je peux te parler de petites
minutes deviens
fou intimité bien s écoute on t'a
relaissé ta
chance tu étais tu ÉIS parti longtemps
de cette émission ça fait un an que
voilà que tu étais parti là tu reviens
c'est bien gentil tu voilà tu retrouves
tes marques
mais ne va pas trop vite trop hein tu
vois ou pas je pe la refaire alors
refaisla ah refaisla c'était hier soir
après
l'émission m entrepris il m' convient
une part à sa les fa dis on sera 16 avec
toi on sera 17 c'est vrai ou pas mais
non arrête de dire des conneries non
mais il est fou il est force dans sa van
il est malade cel est-ce que c'est vrai
ou estce mais c'est pas vrai je veis
aller en partous après l'émission
pour je vais t'emmener toi en plus tu me
l'as proposé j'ai dit mais non mais non
mais non mais désamorce e désamorceer ce
bordel désamorce-moi ce bordel parce que
les
gens on y croit on y
cro demain à
20h45 par que je sais qu'il m pas quoi
il m jamais
al vous n'y croyez pas à chacun d' non
j'y crois pas on vous don la réponse là
tout de suite on va donner la réponse la
vraie moi j crois vous croyez non r il
bossait très tôt ce matin il m'a dit
qu'il avait liv très tôt fou Daniel moi
j'y crois parce qu'il m'a dit qu'il
m'ainvitait à une soirée hier soir
et le
CH qu' dit une soirée
je est-ce qu'il t dit est-ce qu'il t'as
dit avec toi on sera
disb il m' dit
on lui c'est le 17 toi c'est le
18 non mais c'est fou et il y a un pote
à moi là qui me dit moi j'habite à Succi
j'aurais dû arriver Guillaume Guillaume
calme-toi je connais ta meuf calme-toi
mon guigi calme-toi n'y croyez pas donc
je n'y crois pas parce que hier j'ai
assisté à cette conversation comme je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure
elle était très animée et évidemment
Jean-Michel Jean-Michel mer exagère
c'était pas 16 c'était 14 qui t'a dit
j'ai peut-être mal entendu j'avoue non
mais vous êtes insupportable moi je v
vous dire je vais vous dire ce que j'en
pense après moi j'y croisis j'étais le
19e tu veux pas te calmer toi ah peux
pas te calmer ça t'intéresse pas ou
qu'est-ce qu'il dit le 20e alors
qu'est-ce qu'
dit
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai une chance j'ai une chance
comme je suis le chef ils me mettent
jamais dans leur galère je les vois ils
discutent en loge à côté hein mais moi
je vais vous dire j'ai eu Raymond tout à
l'heure et jeis lui ai demander ce qu'il
avait fait hier soir qu'est-ce tu as
fait hier soir il m'a dit NON NON hier
soir je suis rentré j'ai dormi j'étais
explosé on était au téléphone en plus
c'est ce qu'il m'a dit hier soirer là
quand tu
parlesé une garde
s'il te plaît désamorce si c'est pas
vrai parce que ça va lui faire des
problèmesah me demandez pas de
désamorcer
alors vérité c'est vra
ou le
tourne moi ça à faire je m'en
fous
passire c'était juste après
l'émission dans la loge des
maquillagesentre conf gentiment non à
boire un verre à boire un verre
voilà bravo je bravo bravo
Jean alandre attends Alexandre Alexandre
ouais tu sais que c'est extraordinaire
parce que j'ai fait un film là-dessus ça
fait garder un secret céit la rumeur
dans l'entreprise ouais une fille qui
dit à ses copines alors tu es toute
seule elle m'a MRE d'être toute seule
elle dit non non non j'ai un mec c'est
mon patron c'était Pierre Arditi part ah
ouais c'est ça et tout mais j'ai eu très
peur quand tu m'as dit j'ai fait un film
sur ça je croyais que c'était
ou j'ai eu très peur je me suis dit ouis
je me suis dit
alors il m'a dit franchement là
honnêtement je veux pas être salop voilà
il m'a dit viens on boit un verre
c'était à sa morort effectivement voilà
il m'a dit on sera une quinzaine tout nu
ça va être très
sympa alors
justement